prosecutors say they have a key piece of
evidence in a murder case and the crime
was caught on video
now a security guard is accused of
killing a customer the i-team has
obtained the surveillance video right at
the center of this case and talked with
a viewer who says this isn't the first
time
the security guard has acted violently
vanessa murphy live on las vegas
boulevard right near craig
with what is an exclusive story
well you can see the 7-eleven is now
under construction but
this is the parking lot where metro
police say a security guard
shot and killed a customer now after we
first reported on this a viewer
contacted us to say he believes he saw
the same security guard
dragging a woman by her hair in the
parking lot here
and that was a few weeks before the
alleged murder now
we want to warn our viewers the video
is disturbing also you're going to hear
music in the background
the viewer tells us that music was
playing as that incident was unfolding
[Music]
pedro gutierrez says this was the scene
outside a 7-eleven in
early august of 2020. the security guard
has a woman pinned to
the ground after she says she hit her
with a bottle
gutierrez provided eight news now with
an approximately two and a half minute
clip
which he says he shot on his cell phone
[Music]
bystanders watch as she doesn't let go
of the woman's hair
[Music]
gutierrez says he's a security guard
himself on the las vegas strip
that's unprofessional she shouldn't even
be working for security at
all then a few weeks later just into our
newsroom metro police has arrested the
security guard accused of shooting and
killing tierrez says he believes the
security guard accused in a murder on
august 26 is the same one he saw in the
parking lot
the victim thomas martin was 56 years
old
the i-team talked with his son she
murdered him in cold blood i think
you know she should she should have to
do her time the i-team obtained video at
the center of the criminal case
metro police say this is kasia mitchell
limiting the number of customers in the
store due to covet 19.
detectives say martin was upset she was
letting in other people before him
he cursed at her and threatened to harm
her martin busts in mitchell grabs him
they shove each other
another employee steps in mitchell pulls
out her gun
and points it at martin's face she takes
him out of the store
records reveal that mitchell said martin
lunged at her she got scared and pulled
the trigger
martin was shot in the chest gutierrez
says he wasn't surprised to learn
mitchell was the suspect after seeing
this
a few weeks earlier i wasn't surprised
because her temper was going
up there
prosecutors say mitchell admitted she
had only
recently received that gun as a mother's
mother's day gift so that's a few months
before that alleged
murder she also told them she had failed
her first
firearms training now they also say she
told detectives she wishes she had never
pulled out her gun now i reached out to
her
attorney he said he does not comment on
pending cases